creo que tenemos una muy buena idea del
funcionamiento del hígado una de las
cosas que tratamos cuando hablamos de
nuestro lóbulo hepático es que tenemos
bilis que se produce en el hígado y
fluye a través del conducto hepático
común ahora la bilis se compone de dos
cosas una son los pigmentos biliares los
pigmentos biliares son cosas que le dan
color no son necesariamente importantes
para la función de la bilis y la otra
cosa son sales biliares esta es la parte
más importante es lo que realmente nos
ayuda a emulsionar recuerda este término
emulsionar lo que significa organizar
para finalmente absorber los lípidos de
modo que las sales biliares nos ayudan a
emulsionar los lípidos nos permiten
convertir los lípidos en mi se las que
luego se absorben en él y león'
así que demos un paso atrás para tener
una mejor idea de cómo funciona
realmente nuestro árbol biliar
recordemos que el hígado sintetiza la
bilis pero no necesariamente la almacena
la bilis que se produce aquí en realidad
pasa por el conducto hepático común
este es el conducto hepático común que
sale del hígado así que una vez que se
produce la bilis sale del hígado y tiene
que ir a algún lugar para ser almacenada
donde se almacena uno de los primeros
lugares por los que pasa es este
conducto que se llama conductos ístico
este es el conducto cística y por aquí
fluye la bilis después del conducto
hepático común el conducto cystic o
guiar a la bilis para almacenarla
momentáneamente en un órgano que es como
una bolsa la vesícula biliar la vesícula
biliar tiene un solo propósito almacenar
la bilis aquí es donde la bilis espera
hasta que llega la hora de ser liberada
entonces cuando la bilis llega a nuestra
vesícula biliar que es lo que hace que
de pronto se mueva a otro lugar como lo
mencionara en detalle en otro vídeo la
hormona que causa que la bilis salga de
la vesícula biliar se llama col existe
quinina coles sixto quinina que a menudo
se abrevia se seca ahora este término
puede ser un poco loco pero si alguna
vez escuchaste del proceso
invento quirúrgico llamado colectomía
colecistectomía es simplemente la
extracción de la vesícula biliar de modo
que la col existe quinina causará que la
vesícula biliar se contraiga y cuando la
vesícula biliar se contrae recuerda que
es una bolsa se va a exprimir toda la
bilis que está aquí va a regresar va a
fluir a través del conducto cística y va
a ir a otro lugar el siguiente lugar que
tendrá flujo de bilis es otro conducto
que se llama conducto colédoco el
conducto colédoco es la última parte del
árbol biliar del que estamos hablando y
conduce nuestra bilis hasta que
finalmente llega al tracto
gastrointestinal una vez ahí se libera
la bilis en el duodeno es en el duodeno
o la primera parte del intestino delgado
en el que la bilis finalmente va a
encontrar algo de lípidos y comenzará a
hacer su trabajo emulsión 'no o haciendo
que los lípidos sean más fáciles de
absorber ahora los lípidos no se
absorben en el duodeno
de hecho las sales biliares con los
lípidos de nuestra comida emulsionados
viajar
hasta el león ahora recuerda que el león
es la última parte del intestino delgado
aquí es donde vamos a absorber las sales
biliares y los lípidos emulsionados es
donde ocurre el proceso de absorción el
y león' entonces es donde ocurre la
absorción de las sales biliares y de los
lípidos es en el duodeno donde se
secreta la bilis en el tracto
gastrointestinal entonces la bilis es
secreta en el tracto gastrointestinal
ahora hablamos de lo que le pasa a los
lípidos una vez que se absorben en él y
león' cuando hablamos sobre el intestino
delgado pero qué pasa con las sales
biliares bueno las sales biliares en
realidad van a circular de regreso al
hígado después de haber sido absorbidas
en el león para someterse de nuevo a
este proceso si tuviéramos que revisar
las diferentes paradas que hace la bilis
en este proceso serían número 1 la bilis
se produce en el hígado número 2 pasa a
través del conducto hepático común y
luego fluye a través del conducto cystic
o para ser almacenada
vesícula biliar hasta que recibamos con
éxito quinina como una señal para
decirle a la vesícula que se contraiga y
luego a partir de ahí la bilis sale de
la vesícula biliar y re ingresa al
conducto cystic o supongo que podemos
decir que este es el quinto lugar al que
va se ingresa al conducto cística y
entra en el conducto colédoco el
conducto colédoco es la última parte del
árbol biliar el cual libera su contenido
en el duodeno
finalmente la bilis llega al tracto
gastrointestinal las sales biliares
harán su trabajo para emulsionar los
lípidos que hemos comido y luego las
sales biliares se volverán a absorber en
él y lyon antes de regresar al hígado en
donde se reutilizarán de modo que
reutilizamos algunas de las sales
biliares existentes en el hígado y así
es como funciona el árbol biliar